foreign
[Music]
professionally it's meant everything to
us here
at mug club or in the business of
serving you
the viewer you watching listening right
now
you are the entire reason for our
ability your ability to create this kind
of content truly independently for the
last six years
in my club when Stephen inspired me to
finally set up for my beliefs
strength and free speech and I want it
back now we need to go out remember what
it's all about it's about our children
it's about our future it's about our
safety it's about our country
silent
silence would you be willing to trade
all the dates from this day to that
[Music]
I want to see you alongside me fighting
like hell